in berlin begrüße ich die
politikwissenschaftlerin andrea römmele
guten abend unten abend ich grüße sie
bundeskanzler scholz hat sich in den
vergangenen tagen einiges anhören müssen
wählende führungskraft in der korona
pandemie wurde ihm vorgeworfen
mangelndes engagement beim thema
impfpflicht konnte er dem heute
entgegentreten
es war ein relativ souveräne auftritt
des bundeskanzlers würde ich sagen er
hat sich ganz klar für eine impfpflicht
ausgesprochen also hat da noch mal das
wiederholt was er in der vergangenheit
auch gesagt hat er
hat aber auch gesagt dass er hier nicht
mit einem eigenen also als kanzler nicht
mit einem eigenen gesetzesvorschlag ins
parlament kommen möchte sondern dass er
eben möchte dass sich gruppierungen
innerhalb des parlamentes zusammentun
und vorschläge ausarbeiten
die man dann breit diskutieren möchte
sie war der eindruck der neuen
bundesregierung auch außenministerin
bernburg trat ja auch im bundestag oder
der justizminister buschmann ist die
regierung in den neuen ämtern angekommen
ich würde schon sagen dass sie
einigermaßen angekommen sind sie haben
alles in allem einen souveränen eindruck
hinterlassen aber man muss auch ganz
klar sagen die debatte heute war ganz
klar bestimmt von den corona maßnahmen
von der korona politik und eben die ganz
große frage was passiert mit der
impfpflicht denn mit dem versprechen
dass eine impfpflicht kommen wird oder
mit der aussicht auf eine impfpflicht
ist eben auch kanzler scholz in dieser
amtszeit gestartet
und die diskussion um die impfpflicht
ist ja richtig hochgekocht wir werden
später in der sendung auch noch über
eine aktion des bundespräsidenten
berichten der versucht hat das ein
bisschen zu versachlichen und ruhe
hineinzubringen
glauben sie dass die impfpflicht kommt
ich denke schon dass sie kommen wird ja
ich bin sehr gespannt auf die debatte
die wir hier zu haben werden vielleicht
noch eine sache die ich ergänzen möchte
zu den ausführungen des kanzlers heute
was die impfpflicht
anbelangt ich finde es gut dass wir eine
debatte haben werden wir brauchen hierzu
auch eine breite debatte das haben wir
vielleicht in den letzten jahren auch
viel zu wenig gesehen in den zeiten der
großen koalition
aber wichtig ist auch dass wir eine
debatte auf der grundlage von
unterschiedlichen vorschlägen haben und
es wäre auch schön und wünschenswert
wenn es hier vorschläge vom kanzler
beziehungsweise von der regierung geben
wird der grund warum es diese nicht gibt
liegt mit einer ganz großen
wahrscheinlichkeit darin dass die
koalition an sich sich eben auch nicht
einig ist dass die fdp hier vor allem
auch ganz klar sich zum großteil gegen
eine impfpflicht stellt deswegen eben
auch der ja der der umweg würde ich
schon sagen wobei das parlament
natürlich nie ein umweg ist aber
deswegen auch hier
diese diese initiative in die hand des
parlamentes geben ja und die die
startbedingungen die sind schon ziemlich
hart weil politische krisen die korona
pandemie von der ersten minute an mega
stress wie glauben sie wie gut ist die
neue regierung darauf vorbereitet
kann es ist sicherlich sehr gut auf mega
stress und diese großen
herausforderungen
vorbereitet weil er ja auch teil der
alten regierung war und auch jetzt in
den letzten zwei jahren praktisch im
ausnahmezustand gearbeitet hat insofern
denke ich mir dass die regierung hier
ganz gut vorbereitet ist die fdp und die
grünen haben sehr gute oppositionsarbeit
in den letzten zwei jahren auch in
dieser großen krisen zeit geleistet
alles in einem gut vorbereitet sie haben
soeben vollen kurz angedeutet dass die
parteien sicher in vielen punkten nicht
so richtig einig waren und zum teil auch
noch immer nicht sind glauben sie
trotzdem dass sich diese drei parteien
ja vernünftig zusammen gefunden haben
sie werden sich noch weiter
zusammenfinden müssen sie haben sich ja
ein motto gegeben mehr fortschritt wagen
und dieses motto dieses narrativ soll
und wird sie auch zusammen halten aber
klar ist auch dass es führung braucht um
diese koalition zusammenzuhalten und das
hat olaf scholz ja auch von sich gesagt
er sagt wer führung bestellt bekommt
führung heute in der auseinandersetzung
hat er von demokratisch leadership
gesprochen also von einem führen
vielleicht eher von der seite oder von
hinten her die stärkung des parlamentes
was übrigens das ist mir auch noch ein
ganz zentraler punkt was übrigens in
nach der langen zeit der exekutive
krisenzeiten sind ja bekanntlich zeiten
in denen die exekutive noch stärker im
vordergrund steht uns allen gut tut als
es das parlament wieder in den
mittelpunkt rückt
aber führung vielleicht in dieser
situation nicht nur von hinten und nicht
nur von der seite sondern von vorne wäre
hier gefragt aber den gedanken zum
parlament dann setze ich gerne noch mal
vor die rolle des bundestages die soll
ja bei dem thema impfen ich zum beispiel
aber auch bei anderen themen gestärkt
werden war das heute ein parade tag für
den bundestag
es war ich meine diese offenen debatten
diese diese fragestunde ist immer eine
eine hochzeit für den bundestag für die
parlamentarische debatte und was jetzt
mit der impfpflicht kommen soll oder mit
der diskussion um die impfpflicht kommen
soll ist eben eine breite
parlamentarische
debatte und das ist sicher nicht gut so
hier müssten müssen wir zu einer
gemeinsamen lösung und zu einer
gemeinsamen position kommen und das
kommt man nur durch den inhaltlichen
austausch und durch das abklopfen von
unterschiedlichen positionen das sind
sternstunden des
bundestags sternstunden der
parlamentarischen debatte
aufhebung der fraktionsdisziplin so dass
jeder abgeordnete jeder abgeordnete nur
seinem gewissen gegenüber verantwortlich
ist das ist alles gut so trotzdem würde
ich mir wünschen dass es eine klar einen
vorschlag von seiten der regierung gibt
weil parlamentarische debatte braucht
auch die grundlage auf der sie
diskutieren muss und braucht vor allem
in krisensituationen auch führung vielen
dank für diese analyse an die
politikwissenschaftlerin andrea o malley
dankeschön sehr gerne